former vice president biden's been
critical of president trump's covet
response
the former vp now saying he would shut
the country down
again if scientists recommended it take
a look
i would shut it down i would listen to
the scientist
i don't blame him for the code crisis i
blame him for
walking away and not dealing with the
solutions
and the idea of saying that this is
going to go away
this is a miracle is going to happen
i've been pleading with the president
for the last three months you need a
plan
and president trump he's hitting back
calling out biden over the comments
biden the other day said no he'd shut it
down he'd listen to some guy say
and he'd shut it down
we just broke a record on jobs an
all-time record
most of the country is right now doing
very very well they've done an
incredible job
and to have a man sitting on television
the other day saying oh i'd shut it down
like it's easy shut it down uh greg
do you think it's a bad idea for the
former vice president to say he'd listen
to scientists
uh well he should have listened sooner
but i love the pro-biotin media
because out of one side of their mouth
they're fretting about the unemployment
numbers
but then the other side of their mouth
they're screaming for more shutdown
which led to the high unemployment
numbers that's the beauty of being an
lip a low information pundit or
lip you can say whatever you want
because you hat you don't remember it
joe also said that you would have saved
40 000 lives if the shutdown was two
weeks sooner but why just two weeks joe
why not four weeks why are you drawing
the line there
what if we'd done the shutdown at the
beginning of january or at christmas the
fact is we couldn't
why was that because joe biden and his
brood were saturating the american brain
with something called impeachment
what elbowed that which elbowed out all
coveted attention
to the disgust of me because i was
talking about covid
so that is why impeachment wasn't
mentioned at their convention
not only because it failed but also
because it killed thousands of people
through distraction and trump's gotta
bring this up trump should say
imagine people imagine people january
and february without impeachment
we could have had a faster handle on
kovid
if they hadn't been chasing the fantasy
of impeachment because he's right
and that's a terrible impression i'll
give it to you i'll give it to you i got
the idea
uh kennedy uh you know what strikes me
here is that we saw what happened
when president trump didn't listen to
the scientists said this thing will
magically disappear
the you know you can go back to church
on easter i think the us has four
percent of the world's population 25
of its deaths that's a terrible record
for not listening
yeah no it's it's awful and and the
disease has really
ravaged communities and and families and
there's no doubt about that
uh but a lot of that is because
of the bureaucratic institutions that
were inherited
by this administration i don't think
that the president has a perfect record
in dealing with covid
but my problem with joe biden is he's
not forward-looking at all
and he's not really talking about
solutions that will make people's lives
better and i don't get a sense of
urgency and greg's absolutely right you
cannot have it both ways you cannot have
an economy that is shut down and then
complain about the fruits of the
shutdown the rotting fruits of the
shutdown
that's incredibly disingenuous but i
don't get a lot of vision from that and
joe biden's also talking about raising
taxes
let me remind you mr former vice
president taxation is
theft and it's not a solution
so dana uh as i was saying in the
earlier segment
as you know the democrats want to make
this a referendum election
and part of that is to say the democrats
believe in science
on so many issues but specifically on
coven
and that they're willing to follow the
signs to protect us americans
so what do you think well i talked to
somebody today who's pretty um
high up there on the in the democratic
circles um and i asked him i said does
this message work for you like listen to
a scientist but we'll do what the
scientists say
and he said yes that for the democrats
they're polling
independents and he said even some
republicans like that message however
i feel like that is just it's too black
and white it ignores some of the things
that we've already learned
we learn we know a lot more than we did
in january and february about
how the virus is spread we know that the
three things really work
masks uh social distancing and hand
washing
we also have some therapeutics now that
are very helpful so
there's you see states that are actually
making some progress especially in like
arizona and florida also very important
for all of those people that live there
but if you are joe biden or donald trump
you're paying very close attention to
those battleground states
i feel that if the issue was put to the
voters should we do another
strict lockdown given all these other
things that we know about how to protect
ourselves and each other
then i think it would probably be 80
percent against
another full lockdown like that unless
it was absolutely warranted so
i i don't see that happening with the
coronavirus now in 2008 joe biden
said of rudy giuliani that he was just
noun
verb 9 11. and you could almost say the
same thing now about joe biden right now
verb coven maybe it will work for him
but
i think that as these states see some
progress and
hopefully people are doing all the right
things with those but
the things i mentioned like the hand
washing and social distancing and masks
that maybe we can
get everybody back to school and work
and be healthy too oh that's a prayer
uh jesse i was thinking to myself that
because the president downplayed the
impact of covet initially uh that his
announcement yesterday
just came off as a a dud i mean you know
people don't know if it's true or not
true you know what's the importance of
this therapy
but it seems like he has sacrificed his
credibility on covet
maybe it was a dud to you on but if you
had the virus and your doctor
said these are some antibodies and
plasma that we're going to give you to
save your life
i guarantee you juan you'd take it
so juan i i think that joe biden is
really just being a simpleton he's not
being scientific there is no way
if we could go back and redo the april
shutdown situation we do it in the same
way
we would not do a blanket 50 state
economic lockdown for six weeks
this is a virus that kills people who
are over 65
80 percent of the deaths over 65. you
would do targeted lockdowns and
quarantines
to the sick and elderly you would do
travel bans which biden was against
and you do hygiene and masks and social
distancing we know so much more now
about the mortality rate
that maybe stuffing intergenerational
families
into small new york city apartments
without masks maybe wasn't a good idea
and we know the cost psychologically
medically and economically
of blanket lockdowns there'd be no way
we're ever going back to that
science is not mathematics it develops
as you get new information
you change and you pivot biden has not
pivoted
and for you to act like fauchian berks
in january
said lock down the economy and trump
waited until mid-march that's not true
24 hours after they advised him
to lock down the economy he pulled the
trigger
that was when joe biden was out there
campaigning and name calling
so i think we need to get that straight
five straight weeks name calling
oh down remember xenophobic five
straight weeks
of us going down in cases
hospitalizations and deaths
and now we have a very good perspective
with this plasma
that's good news for the american people
it's not a dud
all right thanks jesse you're welcome